the moment Court opens this morning Elon
Musk is reportedly going to destroy
left-wing cancel mob and Michael noll's
publicist Media Matters with facts and
lawsuits the promise from musk follows a
report from Media Matters last week
alleging that X formerly known as
Twitter is serving up mainstream
corporate ads next to neonnazi content
boa booa Booga very scary the biggest
corporations in the country immediately
took the bait Apple IBM Disney Warner
Brothers Discovery Comcast NBC Universal
Lionsgate Paramount Global all announced
they were pulling ad money from the
platform here's the report very scary it
looked like Media Matters had won they
had finally caught Elon with his pants
down
until Elon pulled up the backend data
and discovered that Media Matters had
made the whole thing up according to the
actual X logs of the 5.5 billion ad
Impressions that were served the day
that Media Matters conducted its
research fewer than 50 not 50 million
not 50 5 were served alongside the
content highlighted by Media Matters the
data showed that for one quote brand
showcased in the article two of its ads
served adjacent to two posts three times
and that ad was only seen in that
setting by one
user the author of The Media Matters
article in other words the whole thing
was a hoax Media Matters made a bunch of
dummy accounts and then gamed the
algorithm relentlessly until they could
get even a handful of examples to back
up its fraudulent claim all of which
prompted musk to declare
quote the Split Second Court opens on
Monday excorp will be filing a
thermonuclear law suit against Media
Matters and all those who colluded in
this fraudulent attack on our company
now I am torn on the one hand musk is
obviously right and frankly we've all
known that Media Matters and the other
left-wing cancel groups the ADL
right-wing watch all the rest of them
have been pulling this sort of fraud for
years this is what they do but on the
other
hand I love the free publicity that
Media Matters gives me I love it there
are at least two Media Matters employees
who are paid to watch my show and then
clip out and promote the best segments
from my show they do it better than the
daily wire employees do a lot of the
time it's faster it's before my show's
over they've got the clips
up but I am willing to put my selfish
desires aside for the good of the
country if it wasn't clear before it
should be now elon's buying Twitter was
a complete Game Cher for conservatives
it gave us our first foothold into the
big Tech platforms that control our
Public Square Elon is taking a lot of
slings and arrows for us but the
foothold seems to be working and scaring
the libs to death and they're scared
because they know that big Tech
censorship was indispensable to their
rigging of the 2020 election and if 2024
is a rematch as it's looking like it
will be then their inability to censor
conservatives this time around might
might
just cost them the election I'm Michael
nolles this the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show it's
finally here the best deal of the Year
50% off new dailywire plus annual
memberships go to daily /s subscribe
right now to
join Kanye West has a new song we'll get
to it but first I don't want to move on
quite yet from these radical
libertarian uh wrenches in the leftwing
system that govern us not not just uh
Elon Musk but also the soon to be
president of Argentina Javier melay who
no one really knows anything about but I
think a lot of people especially on the
right realize uh represents a major
change in Argentina and a change that is
positive and a and a lurching to the
right here is just one clip from Mr mle
I'll translate because you can't give
leftards an inch can you define
leftist the interviewer asks all
collectivists all kinds of
collectivists why do you call them
because they are
if you think different from them
they will kill you this is the point you
can't give leftists an inch if you
give them an inch they will use it to
destroy you you can't negotiate with
leftards
goodness you don't negotiate with trash
because they will end you that's this
guy when he won he just starts like
jumping around the stage he's got crazy
looking hair he is very much a trumpian
figure in the looks in the bombastic
Lang language in the political program
he has a more right-wing populist kind
of agenda that not issue for issue but
almost issue for isue maps onto Trump
which is great that's good news for
Argentina but you you know it's it's
just not in the
conservative ethos to to just jump for
joy and be totally happy and say the
future's going to be bright it's not we
always need a little Wrinkle in there
okay we can and here's the little
wrinkle is that you could describe
Javier mle as a radical right-wing
conservative I
guess but you could probably more
accurately describe Javier mle as a
radical liberal he's a radical
libertarian he has certain eccentric
political views he's he's wrapped
philosophic about the benefits of
tantric sex and orgies and things like
that he has uh described you using media
media meaning like the plural of mediums
like psychic mediums to communicate with
dogs and he he's he's described
channeling the spirits of Ein Rand and
so I don't mean any of this to knock him
okay I just want to point out he's not
this isn't going to be the
reestablishment of the Holy Roman Empire
over here he's a radical libertarian and
that is preferable to some radical
Progressive leftist but it's not quite
the same thing as a traditionalist
conservative okay and if you look around
the the political environment a radical
libertarian might be the the first step
that we need we might not have a whole
lot of other options here okay I don't
think we're going to have a jackaby
rising and the restoration of you know
the old regime in France or anything
like that okay we might this might be
the best that we can get jav Javier
Malay is really good on abortion it
seems he's really good on crime he's
really good on uh
economic uh flourishing he's he's an
economist by trade he's really good on
recognizing threats from the political
left he's really good on inspiring the
people bringing the people in you know
that deplorable irredeemable hooy that
the leftists hate he brings them into a
popular political movement one hopes
that his election Heralds good things
for the future just as the brexit in the
UK was a sign a augured very well and
made it seem as though uh Donald Trump
might be elected and then he was elected
in 2016 perhaps mle's election in 2023
in Argentina shows good signs for 2024
in the United
States but when you look at all the
really big right-wing wins they tend to
come from more libertarian minded people
uh javay was asked about homosexual
uality and there there are
other right right-wing strong men you
know in in Latin America who have had
clearer views on family on the
complimentarity of the Sexes on
tradition and social order someone like
xer bolsonaro who said no we're not
going to be encouraging Pride parades
let's put it that way and mle is not one
of those mle seems to be totally fine
with some of the aspects of the sexual
revolution in much the same way that
Trump is you know don't forget Trump was
the most Pro LGBT candidate ever to run
for office I think in either party he
was more Pro LGBT during his race in
2016 than Barack Obama was during his
first
race
so I I I just don't want us celebrating
too much okay I I love that Malay was
elected I'm I I think it bodess well for
Argentina and for the world but I'm not
going to say three cheers for Javier
Malay yet I'm going to say two cheers
for Javier Malay and we'll see what
happens if if he's got a kind of social
conservatism to him he's clearly got an
opposition to the radical leftists but
can we can we Channel this this reaction
against collectivism can we Channel this
reaction against the leftist lunatics
the the in Javier malays words
libtards or whatever leftards that he
calls them can we channel that popular
sentiment into to a profound and
enduring uh coherent conservatism I hope
so we'll have to see now one thing that
those radical Libertarians love is gold
so you got to check out Birch gold right
now text nolles to 98 9898 we are facing
the threat of a potential government
shutdown and the administration will
ultimately deal with it the same way
they always do with more spending more
spending will inevitably devalue the
dollar protect your savings by
diversifying into gold with the help of
Birch gold group when you open an IRA
with Birch gold for every $10,000 you
spend by December 22nd Birch gold will
send you a free gold bar just text n can
to 9898 98 to claim eligibility before
Black Friday Birch gold can even help
you convert an existing Ira or 401K into
an IRA in Gold without taking any money
out of pocket are you still listening
because you get a free gold bar it's a
big deal with an A+ rating with a Better
Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied customers you can count on
Birch gold to help you transition an
existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold
don't let your savings fall victim to
the further devaluation of the dollar
Tex nolles canid to 9898 98 receive a
free info kit on gold and claim your
eligibility before Black Friday to
receive free gold bars on your
qualifying purchase that is NZ can to
9898 98 speaking of potentially decisive
conservative wins uh speaker Mike
Johnson has now promised to release
44,000 hours of January 6th footage so
Nancy Pelosi and the Democrats they had
all the January 6th footage but they
realized that it contradicted their
fraudulent narrative that they had made
the Janu sorry sorry excuse me I'm sorry
I misspoke I meant to
say
janary 6 the worst day in the history of
this or any Republic the day that
democracy almost
collapsed uh we were told that it was an
Insurrection near hou d' that nearly
shredded the
Constitution democracy just was on the
brink of total Annihilation or sacred
Temple of democracy the capital was
attacked which just wasn't even true it
was just a a bunch of Ecentric people
walking through the capital compared to
the actual leftist attacks on the
capital that have happened at least half
a dozen times in recent decades where
where radical leftists set off bombs
started shooting congressmen that's sort
of thing which happened not in the
distant past but just some decades
ago we were told that January 6 the
podium guy you know the Nancy Pelosi
lean guy waving at the cameras or the
horn hat guy walking through getting a
private tour Guided by the capital
police of the capital that that was the
grave threat to democracy turned out not
to be true Tucker Carlson was able to
release some of the January 6 footage
now Mike Johnson says he's going to
release the rest of it Brandon straa had
a a good take on this which is he
tweeted out just a little bit of footage
showing a handful of people walking
through the
capital again not tearing things down
not shooting people not vandalizing
anything there's one guy in particular
he's wearing a red Maga sweater and he's
just he's just videoing he's walking
very politely there are capital police
there they're just letting them do it
they don't really no no one's seems all
that nervous certainly no one seems
violent at all the cops don't seem
worried in the
least and they keep walking there's more
cops there okay they're just just just
walking everyone's
chilling be sitting there sipping a cup
of coffee no big deal right so that guy
in the red
sweater who's taking the video his name
is Matthew Perna sorry let me rephrase
that his name was Matthew Perna he was
calmly walking through the capital and
then he was charged by the leftwing
gestapo and he was told that he might
face 6 to 12 months in
prison uh if if if this thing went to
trial and so he he just plead guilty he
said okay I'm going to plead guilty so I
don't need to go to prison for 6 to 12
months after he plead guilty Joe Biden's
doj informed him that it would seek a
terrorism enhancement to his sentencing
because I don't know maybe that's the
same iPhone that Al-Qaeda uses or
something I don't know what on Earth
could possibly justify a terrorism
enhancement this happened to a lot of
the January Sixers though so he was told
he would face a terrorism enhancement
which could raise the sentence to a
potential 9 years in federal prison but
hey they already tricked him into
pleading guilty so they had him right
four days after receiving that news
Matthew went into his garage and put a
rope around his neck and hanged
himself not the only case of of total
despair coming from this political
persecution that was not really grounded
in reality how many lives were ruined
for this hoax who's responsible for that
Nancy Pelosi certainly the Democrats
certainly Liz Cheney certainly Adam
kininger certainly them perhaps more
than the others even because the they
were fake conservatives you know rhinos
they they were Republicans in name only
in the truest sense of that term meaning
that they their entire raise on debt in
in Washington was to put on a
performance as a republican but at all
the crucial moments they would side with
the Democrats whenever it really counted
whenever the Democrats needed some some
semblance of an of an actual opposition
they would sit on the January 6th
committee but the January 6th committee
ostensibly investigating what happened
on January 6th actually served the
opposite purpose they covered it up it
was a big
hoax and they they made sure that as
long as they had any power at all they
would keep the tapes that that
showed what really happened on that day
that exculpated a lot of people uh they
would keep that to themselves and people
died because of that the only people who
died in the political violence and
subsequent political
persecution of that
day
were
conservatives or were people who felt
hounded by the left the only person who
died in the political violence of that
day was Ashley babbett she was killed by
a trigger happy cop she was a trump
supporter and then how many people
killed themselves because of the
hounding from the left so anyway Mike
Johnson is going to release all that and
I think it's really really important
really really important that we in as
much as we possibly can hold these
people to account because we are told by
the left and by the squishes move on
from 2020 move on don't talk about it
anymore this is one of the biggest
attacks on Trump stop talking about
January 6th and stop talking about the
2020 election how are we going to stop
talking about it we're running again
almost certainly with the same candidate
there are still people who are being
prosecuted there are people who who have
sat in prison for years because of the
nonsense of of the January 6th
investigators and
prosecutors and we're we're probably
going to have a rematch of the 2020
election so if you don't change any of
the rigging if you don't shed some light
on the ways that the the left
cheated and and persecuted people who
had the audacity to vote against the
ruling party the Democrats how are you
possibly going to have a fair election
in 2024
can't do it the only way out is through
okay guys you can't just move on and
keep your I guess if you want to be like
a Liz Cheney Adam kinzinger Republican
and you want to just lose with dignity
no dignity involved whatsoever by the
way then fine but if you want to be an
actual conservative an actual Republican
you can't just move on what the left did
in 2020 and in the days following 2020
was horrific what was a resetting of our
political order and was downright evil
in these cases that led to Despair and
and death and imprisonment for bogus
reasons you can't just move on from that
you got to fix that if you don't want it
to happen again in the future speaking
of that Insurrection Insurrection a
Colorado judge was just tasked with
deciding whether or not to kick Donald
Trump off the ballot because the left is
arguing that Donald Trump is
disqualified for from running again
under the 14th Amendment because the
14th Amendment says if you've ever been
a traitor and you've LED an Insurrection
against the country then you are
disqualified from from public
office and the judge just ruled that
that is a ridiculous argument of course
it's a ridiculous argument and and
actually the way that this judge issued
the ruling is particularly devastating
for the leftwing case because this judge
is not some Trump appointee she's not
some Republican she is a left-wing judge
she was appointed by the left-wing
Democrat Governor of color
and she even believes that January 6th
constituted an Insurrection and still
she says that this argument is
ridiculous she ruled that the
Insurrection Clause of the 14th
Amendment does not apply to the
presidency even though the capitol Riot
was a quote Insurrection and that she
believes Trump meant to quote incite
political violence I love this even some
hysterical lib judge in color
which has become super leftwing ever
since they legalized the Haitian oregano
everyone's just walking around high as a
kite all the time muttering ridiculous
lib phrases like Insurrection and
political violence or whatever and even
still she says she she put the bong down
long enough I don't want to accuse her
of being a pothead you know we're at a
new era Snoop Dogg is giving up weed I
don't want to make some claim based on
nothing that this judge is a big pothead
she's a liberal it's bad enough and even
she acknowledges
even she acknowledges guys this 14th
Amendment Insurrection it's complete
nonsense you can't keep the man off the
ballot for that and I think what's
implicit in all of these cases is the
only reason they're trying to keep Trump
off the ballot is because they know that
if they put him on the ballot a lot of
people maybe most people maybe most
people in the crucial states are going
to vote for him just like they did in
2016 very important and why might people
want to reelect Donald Trump well one
reason one big reason for me is that
he's the most pro-life president in my
lifetime and he was instrumental and an
essential piece of the story of getting
roie Wade overruled and if you're a
prolifer you got to check out pre-born
right now go to pre-born docomo we talk
about pre-born a lot on this show it's
because we believe in their mission and
we know that you do too who would not
want to help mothers and their children
in crisis pre-born is an organization
dedicated to saving the lives of The
Unborn every day pre-born network of
clinics rescues 200 babies as they
compete head-to-head with the abortion
Giants they offer free ultrasounds to
mothers considering abortion and once
she sees her baby and hears its
heartbeat she is twice as likely to
choose life it it basically doubles the
baby's chance at surviving and right now
through a matching program your tax
deductible gift is itself doubled 100%
of your gift will go toward providing
free ultrasounds to mothers in crisis as
well as supporting mothers and their
babies with diapers car seats counseling
and more Now's the Time of the Year
everyone's writing their checks it's
time to get the write offs I usually
wait until New Year's Eve don't be like
me do it now double down today by
dialing pound 250 say the keyword baby
that is pound 250 or go to pre-born
docomo preborn docomo
wle speaking of legal attacks on liberal
strongholds the Department of Education
is now investigating seven
schools seven colleges and universities
including three Ivy League schools
for alleged incidents of anti-Semitism
and anti-muslim
harassment those schools
include Lafayette Welsley isn't Welsley
the school that what's her face went to
that my cousin Hillary Clinton went to I
think so Cooper Union
and uh Public School District in can
Kansas so not even just the colleges and
universities and then of the Ivy League
schools Columbia Cornell and
upen now this is obviously a problem at
these campuses I was just at Cornell and
I was at Cornell one week after some kid
threatened to murder all the Jews on
campus and slit the throats of the
Jewish men and do all sorts of
unspeakable things to the Jewish women
and even was threatening Jewish babies
and it was really I mean this is real
I'm not denying that this is real there
are obviously threat threats and
harassment against Jewish students for
sure
and the D the doe is trying to be even
handed here and they're saying we're
going to investigate anti-islamic
incidents too I haven't seen a ton of
those I haven't heard about a lot of
those but I don't know maybe those are
happening too I'm not I'm not going to
say that they are certainly not
happening and both of those things
certainly should be investigated and
absolutely I'm all I am fine with the
state going after these big bloated
schools that are little more than
indoctrination centers for leftism but I
got to
ask what about the anti-christian
harassment I'm not denying in any way
that there is anti-jewish harassment and
I'm somewhat skeptical but I'm willing
to grant that there's anti-islam
harassment but what about the
anti-christian harassment and if you're
going to look at this from a racial
point point of view if you're saying
well they're attacking the Jews cuz the
Jews are a tribe or they're attacking
the Muslims cuz they're Arab and there's
anti-arab sentiment okay yeah maybe
there is I I don't deny any of that what
about the anti-white
sentiment which is pervasive at all of
these schools there's one big
distinction between these various types
the anti-jewish the anti-muslim the
anti-arab versus the anti-christian and
often the anti-white the big distinction
is in the former category those
incidents are kids or towns
people just
vandalizing things I don't know you know
drawing swastikas an off-handed comment
here or there in the case of the
anti-christian and anti-white harassment
that's coming from the classrooms okay
and those incidents are not happening
late at night at an off-campus party or
through vandalism on a dorm room wall
the anti-christian and anti-white
harassment is coming from the faculty
and the administration it's coming from
professors who say that we need to
abolish whiteness that that's a goal
worth pursuing it's coming from the
professors in the administration
who are decrying Christianity is an
awful imperialist religion that's
completely bogus anyway and even if it
weren't bogus it's led to all sorts of
terrible things through all of human
history that's a big distinction and I'm
opposed to all of
it yeah keep that I love it keep that
investigation up of the anti-islam even
and the anti-Semitism and sure keep
those investigations up when are we it's
not going to be under the Biden
Administration but when are we going to
have the
political coones and the correct moral
vision and the spine let's talk about
other anatomical features that are a
little closer to the intellect when are
we going to have the courage and the
moral Clarity to stand up against that
because that is the kind of harassment
that is happening with the official
sanction of the universities the
professors and the administrators now
speaking of the Jews and the Muslims and
the war in the Middle East the United
States is reportedly close to a deal for
a at least temporary ceasefire to free
some
hostages uh this is being reported now
in the in the press and it's being
widely reported that this deal would
free dozens of women and children held
hostage in Gaza in exchange for a 5day
pause in the fighting uh say people
familiar with the emerging terms and I
actually I was having a little bit of a
debate on this issue with Professor
Jacob this morning because this I I
assume this was just a good thing but
Professor Jacob said well if you have a
5day ceasefire then Hamas might be able
to reconstitute itself so it's not a
totally uncontroversial
thing I still think it's good I think
that's what we want the reason I think
this is good is because the hostages are
the key issue here the hostages one I
think it's good to free the hostages I
don't want the hostages to be held
hostage any longer by Hamas and these
other lunatics but two the hostages are
the key point of escalation
here so long as the hostages are being
held in Gaza the war can't end and the
prospect of escalation whether that's
from Iran whether that's from Lebanon
whether that's from China and Russia
whether that's from the United States
whether that's from the houes in Yemen
whether that's from who knows we've
already got a lot of powers involved in
this war the prospect of escalation is
much much higher so I'm all for it I'm
not backing necessarily the popular
leftwing call for a total
ceasefire to say well you know gaza's
been punished enough or something I
totally recognize that the state of
Israel cannot tolerate the security risk
of another October 7th attack cannot
tolerate the security risk of Hamas
continuing to rule in Gaza totally
recognize that frankly if if Hamas is
allowed to continue to govern in Gaza in
the long run that's probably going to
lead to a greater likelihood of War but
if we could get a a brief ceasefire in
exchange for host hostages that seems I
think good for everybody but it's
certainly good for the US interest I am
all for it now speaking of Foreign
Affairs speaking of China
China xiin ping was just in our
country and you know they fixed up San
Francisco for him it's amazing we we've
been told by the liberal politicians who
run San Francisco in California for
years that they can't do anything about
it the bums on the streets the criminals
the vagrants the people dying of
exposure the druggies there's nothing
that can be done and then xiin ping
shows up for what 2 days and San
Francisco all of a sudden is completely
better can we get shiin ping to go on a
national tour can we bring him to New
York and DC Seattle and Chicago oh man
bring xinping to Chicago they'll have
that place cleaned up overnight I'm not
a big fan of the Chinese Communist party
but look I'm a I'm a pragmatic fellow if
xiin ping taking a brief vacation to one
of our cities manages to clean it up
after Decades of liberal neglect I'm all
for it let's go the other big
announcement that came with she's
arrival here is that China has now
launched the world's fastest
internet this is internet with a 1.2
terabit per second link this is not only
blowing the us out of the water on this
technology but it's also years ahead of
the forecasts for China getting this
technology the the Chinese Network can
now send the equivalent of 150 movies
per second this is three times faster
than the nearest rival in the United
States two years earlier than industry
forecasts this has got to be scary stuff
if you are a bellicose American patriot
who doesn't want China to overtake you
on the world stage because what we do
especially American conservatives is we
lie to ourselves and we say all those
Chinese Communists they're Communists so
they've got some economic system that's
never going to work we're we already
beat communist ISM we won the Cold War
same thing's going to happen in China we
don't need to worry about it forget
about it oh things are bad in China
actually they they've got problems look
I read about it in western media so they
got problems I'm not worried at all you
you you should be somewhat
concerned I I don't ever think anyone
should live in servile fear or stay up
at night worrying about some foreign
country
but you can't just write off China as
communist okay yes they xiin ping uses
communist rhetoric sometimes but what
describes is socialism with Chinese
characteristics and if you actually go
in and read his speeches there's a lot
to them that is fairly conservative a
lot of social
conservatism he's been routing a lot of
LGBT propaganda out of his movies out of
his
culture but but even on
economics if that's the primary way
you're looking at
politics xiin ping promotes economic
liberalization in certain areas when it
is serving the national interest okay
this guy does not sound like an orthodox
by the book Marxist leninist far from it
okay in some ways the guy sounds like a
national conservative actually okay and
that should give us all a little bit of
pause because it means that xiin ping is
a clever fellow who's going to avoid
some of the pitfalls that the Soviet
Union fell into and it it could lead the
United States to a global war you know
's this concept promoted by the Harvard
political scientist Graham Allison
called the thusi Trap the notion is that
when a rising power challenges a
dominant power the result usually is war
that it seems almost
inevitable Graham Allison has pointed
out that 3ars of the time of the last
major changes to the global order the
last whatever is upwards of 20 changes
in in 3ars of those cases War major war
has been the result so do we want that
do we really think that the United
States is in a good position to to wage
a global war primarily against China is
that something that we desire it's not
something I desire and I'm skeptical
about our ability to do it particularly
when China owns the country because
because they're our main creditor and
whenever we want to wage our our Wars of
Empire around the world we borrow the
money from
China particularly when China
manufactures all our stuff particularly
when the biggest American companies who
who promote who who produce the most
important American material products
talking about companies like apple when
they when they do the vast majority of
their Manufacturing in China when for
some reason American liberals let China
into the World Trade Organization and
said a rising tide lifts All Ships and
it's good to see China rise and then
China spent the next 20 years stealing
all of our intellectual property so they
got it they got it they've got our
intellectual property guys you you
really think now is a great time to wage
a war on China America says that we
can't even clean up our cities can't
enforce our border can't do basic basic
political things and then xiin ping
shows up for two days and everything's
fixed that's that should give us pause
and and she knows this she knows that
the the risk of war is pretty high and
he's trying to head it off uh this has
not been reported almost anywhere but
she gave a speech to us CEOs here's what
he said he said the number one question
for us is are we adversaries or
Partners this is the fundamental and
overarching issue the logic is quite
simple if one sees the other side as a
primary competitor the most
consequential geopolitical Challenge and
a pacing threat it will only lead to
misinformed policymaking misguided
actions and unwanted results China is
ready to be a partner and friend of the
United States the fundamental principles
that we follow in handling China us
relations are mutual respect peaceful
coexistence and win-win
cooperation so he's speaking very
bluntly and he's saying yeah I read the
thusi Trap essay too and I know I know
know that we we could be headed toward
war and I'm willing to avoid war but you
need to recognize I'm not just some
Backwater and I'm not just some stupid
communist dictator who's headed for the
ash heap of History what we've done in
China has been working really really
well and you guys in the west have been
giving up all of your competitive
advantages not just your material
advantages largely to us but are your
political advantages your philosophical
advantages and your certainly your
theological advantages I think is impc
in any sober analysis of the situation
so you you've forgotten what inspires
you you forgot what made your country
great you forgot what made your
civilization great now you're a dying
civilization and you're on the decline
in virtually every measure you can't
even control your streets you can't even
control your border and we're on the
rise and if you want to just keep your
head in the sand and deny that until
it's too late and go to war okay don't
blame it on
me that is a he said it in really nice
words
and xinping is really friendly and
smiley and he's ping around with all his
his Democrat politician buddies in
America but this is a
threat it's it's a a promise basically
that there will be War if the US doesn't
get smart and doesn't get smart fast my
favorite comment yesterday is from the
mob seat who says imagine having your
brain in a haze oh this is this is with
regard to Snoop diggity doogy dog giving
up the devil's lettuce he says imagine
having your brain in a haze and walking
out of the fog after 30 plus years he'll
feel like he's on another planet so true
although the the thing is if he entered
into this Mary Jane infused Haze 30
years ago then he's going to come out of
it and he's going to look at reality
right now and he's going to say he's
going to say what the hell is going on
here he'll probably say like what the
hisle is going on with the Frizzle you
know you know but he'll he'll because
he's got to come out of it a little bit
you know he's not just going to sober up
immediately but but once he does sober
up he looks around he's say wait what
okay pass the bong again please because
this world is far crazier than any
hallucination I ever had back in the
early 90s smoking the sin spinach by now
you've heard the dailywire plus annual
memberships are 50% off during the Black
Friday sale but there are so many more
great deals waiting for you check out
the dailywire Black Friday shopping
guide at dailywire.com sblack Friday we
are making Black Friday shopping easier
than ever with the best deals of the
Year all in one place find the perfect
gift for the men on your Black Friday
list with up to 40% off Jeremy's razors
most popular products including the
bestselling men's shaving kits and
bundles like the alpha bundle Precision
5 kit and the founders kit from Jeremy's
chocolates to the all new Jeremy's
deodorant start your Black Friday and
finish your Black Friday shopping with
us this year best part is you can stop
giving your money to wot corporations
this Black Friday see all of the best
deals of the Year inside the daily wire
gift guide now at dailywire.com blackf
Friday speaking of
violence there are new outtakes from the
set of that movie that Alec baldon
worked on where he shot and killed that
woman the cinematographer and the
outtakes seem to show and they're being
promoted by NBC which obviously is a
company that Alec baldman has worked for
for much of his career uh
there outakes that seem to show that
Baldwin was in fact concerned about some
of the safety measures or lack thereof
on the set and that he didn't he
expressed his concern he didn't want to
shoot toward the cinematographer the
cinematography should not should should
not have been standing in the line of
fire she should have been probably
looking at a monitor off in the other
direction uh and forget about the
cinematographer for a second the tragedy
that she was killed there were so many
steps along the way so many uh safety
malfunction that occurred before Al
baldman pulled that trigger here he is
and everyone need to be right here like
in the path of the gun could you please
move just want to be over him a little
bit so I can see now wait a second if
I'm going to shoot right you want to go
on the other side of the camera I don't
want to shoot toward you so there you
see him look the Alec Baldwin's a total
Pro and he's there as an actor and he's
saying I don't want to shoot towards you
but apparently they continued in this
Reckless way anyway on the set and
here's a really unpopular opinion this
is going to be unpopular opinion Monday
[Music]
here it's not Baldwin's fault Alec
Baldwin is not responsible for the
shooting on the rust set I know
instantly what people are going to say
is if you have a a firearm it is always
your responsibility what happens with
that firearm if you have a firearm and
you're pointing it at
someone then you need to be ready to
kill that person you want you have to be
ready to destroy whatever you're
pointing at that's basic firearm safety
101 and and that's all true but that's
not movie making 101 movie making if
you're using a gun in a movie it almost
always involves you pointing it and
shooting it at somebody it is not
comparable the the the rules and
regulations you would follow at a gun
range or for any person in regular life
using a firearm it is not comparable to
the way that actors use firearms in
movies and Alec Baldwin here is an actor
the people who are responsible primarily
it's the
armorer the the weapons Master on the
set who was some clueless young girl who
obviously didn't know what she's doing
and the result is that a woman's now
dead the second person responsible would
be the first ad the first assistant
director who goes gets the weapon should
also be checking to make sure that it's
not loaded at all hands it to the actor
the third group responsible I guess
would be the producers and the crew onet
and technically Alec baldman is a
producer here but it's it's only a
technicality he's a producer as a common
Financial workaround for had to pay his
acting contract but he's not that he's
not actually a producer in the way that
in the way that producers produce films
he's an actor primarily in the movie and
everyone's going after him because he's
a jerk and nobody likes him and I know
but I this is my unpopular view throw
tomatoes at me I'm here to tell you the
truth I'm not here to Pander to you okay
they're going after Alec baldman because
he's an easy target because he is a rich
famous straight white guy who has a
legend SC temper and he's just easy to
attack and it's a lot easier to put the
blame on him than on this clueless
armorer whose fault it actually
is
but I if if he were just an unknown
actor very few people would actually be
blaming him for
this I got listen don't ever accuse me
of just carrying water or reciting
talking points guys I'm defending Alec
Baldwin who is a very unlikable liberal
but in this case it's the way it is it's
the way it goes speaking of controversy
commcial entertainers Kanye has a new
song this is his first song ever since
the eccentric shall we say display that
he made like what was it about a year
ago on the Alex Jones Show and with the
face mask and the the yah the net and
yah yooo and where he was going after
the Jews and all that you remember that
thing so anyway he's got a new song out
here is the
[Music]
song
I got and know I didn't put that drop in
there that drop is in the record
[Music]
already We R like
a baby
is baby
is okay you know I think this will be
more actually productive if I just read
the lyrics it's not I don't look I'm not
really even
knocking I am knocking the music I guess
but it's it's not for me this is not I'm
not I'm not a big fan of hip-hop or rap
or most music made in the last 70 or 80
years uh I've liked some of Kanye's
music in the past I like that song that
he wrote with Paul McCartney only one I
thought that was pretty good I've often
thought Kanye is a pretty good uh has a
pretty good ear so he hears good songs
that he then samp and wraps over and I
don't love the rapping but I you know
like Jesus Walks is a great example
that's Jesus walk you know and then
that's a good song and then he wraps
over it and makes it popular so okay uh
this song is with um Ty doign and l
Durk whoever they are and here are the
lyrics Three gang leaders with me all
times I don't know who I effed last
night I got Alzheimer's I don't know who
them ho is man they all lion Brody tell
me who them ho is man they all fine run
and Hool again and we with the
foolishness how how I'm anti-semitic I
just effed a Jewish I just effed
scooter Brawn the that big celebrity
manager uh and we ran up like
Olympics got pregnant in the threesome
whose baby is it whose baby is it my
ninjas he doesn't say ninjas but it's a
word that I'm not allowed to say because
I'm a white fellow uh Puttin belt to a s
pull up with the switches this ain't
Jimmy Butler but the heat got extensions
this ain't Coline but we came in with
the trenches I assume trench coat she
asking me to aim this is a this is a
little toddy this lyric more so even
than the others she asking me to aim for
her neck cuz her boyfriend bought that
necklace with the trenches prees with
the trenches eff it I scratched another
ninja woman up off my checklist okay why
do I read any of
this this is a song about
revenge Kanye is singing There's there
are other verses with other rappers in
it but this is his verse and he's
singing about revenge I don't know who I
effed I got Alzheimer's you can't say
that I don't like Jews I just effed one
of those Jews and I just effed this
other guy's girlfriend and I just I I
disrespected him and a gift that he had
given her yeah I'm just it's not even
about her it's about him and I'm just
getting back at him and I'm getting back
at scooter braa and I'm getting back at
the Jews and I'm getting back at this
guy and I'm getting back at that guy and
I'm just effing everybody and I'm
hitting people and I'm I'm like I'm like
the shooters at Coline I'm dressing up
in trench coats like them it's all about
revenge and it's about revenge Pres
because Kanye got
canceled and he lost a ton of money and
Adidas canceled him and he he'll
probably bounce back to some degree
because the guy just seems to be made of
Teflon even after his uh rather
elaborate breakdown last year but it's
the Revenge to me that's the key because
he made another album not that long ago
called Jesus's King that was actually
somewhat Beautiful by the standards of
modern pop music I think there was a
song on there water we are water like a
newborn daughter and um a friend of mine
actually wrote part of the bridge to
that song actually ironically my a
Jewish friend of mine wrote part of the
bridge to that song but the whole album
was just about how Jesus is King and we
should all be Christian and worship God
and be good and uh rumored during the
making of that album was Kanye's demand
that nobody engage in fornication and he
was trying to save his marriage and a
lot of people go crazy after a divorce
and but he he really seemed to be aiming
at virtue and then here in this new song
as first we heard from him in in over a
year or about a year at
least it's all just about getting back
at people and doing nasty things and
fornicating and hitting people and you
know and vengeance is mine sayeth the
Lord and I will repay and and so I I
feel for the
guy in that it's very easy to to fall
into Vice and to to enjoy the notion of
revenge against people you think have
wronged you but it's not the right way
if you compare this song to The Jesus's
King album Jesus's King album is much
better and Kanye was probably in a much
better place when he was doing that
album okay the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code NS can Wes at
checkout for 2 months free on all annual
[Music]
plans